assault degree third verdict it was a
guilty verdict coach Blakely broke a
clipboard over his quarterbacks head
during halftime at the homecoming game
now in his defense now he gets one John
jr. had his helmet on he just keeps
selling doesn't [ __ ] down
congratulate yeah I mean it's not
official but Celia heard from a good
source he's kind of crazy I'm dating the
hottest girl in school I'm getting
crowned up from once again my license
tomorrow I kind of have everything I've
ever wanted and hashtag blessed you know
sometimes what it needs is a monster and
you believe you know what it is to be a
monster hmm yo Helen no idea she was my
first serious girlfriend why did you
break up that's a strange question did
you treat her band did you cheat on
that's a rude question let me tell you
what Amy told me she dumped you you
completely unraveled you stalked her you
threatened her you attempted suicide in
her bed and we're institutionalized your
wife is missing and you came all this
way to tell me this well I thought there
might be another side of this story